pour rappel sur Stéphane l'animateur est
accusé de violence conjugale sur trois
de ses anciennes compagnes d'entre elles
ont d'ailleurs porté plainte euh
l'animateur devrait tout de même être
bientôt de retour dans les grosses têtes
un retour qui risque d'être d'être
beaucoup commenté euh alors euh juste on
a la réponse la réaction de Stéphane
Plaza VI a un communoqué de son avocate
en exclusité je vais vous la dire dans
un instant juste il va faire son retour
dans les grosses têtes là Stéphane alors
oui il est prévu que début novembre il
revienne dans les grosses têtes de toute
façon il n'a pas arrêté de de tourner
hein là actuellement il est il est en
tournage pour M6 pour les émissions de
de M6 donc il n'a pas du tout arrêté de
travailler et là il va revenir
effectivement moi les infos que j'ai eu
aussi c'est que début novembre il sera
présent dans les grosses têtes Hugo
est-ce que vous avez l'info parce que
c'est quand même lur qui présent bien
sûr bien sûr euh bah en fait non il est
pas programmé c'estàd qu'il a pas encore
de rendez-vous une date après que le
fait que Laurent
l'accueille s'il a envie si Stéphane a
envie et que Laurent accepte qu'il
revienne ça c'est c'est un fait c'est
sûr Laurent va accepter mais par contre
moi je pense que Stéphan n'aura
absolument pas envie de revenir vu les
conditions médiatiques actuelles de
revenir pour faire pour faire un peu le
le faire rire dans les grosses têtes ça
vraiment j'en suis convaincu donc après
il est le bienvenu voilà c'est ça il est
le bienvenu mais je ne pense pas qu'il
viendra mais il est pas boycoté en tout
cas il est pas boycotté ah non il il est
pas boycotté de toute façon Laurent a
donné son point de vue sur la situation
comme Karine marchant justement il il y
a eu des nouveaux éléments puisque Éric
Antoine aussi un autre animateur de M6 a
donné son alors oui é Antoine il
s'estexprimé sur Europa alors ils sont
très très potes avec avec Stéphane Plaza
et du coup il a il a il a parlé sur repa
il a donné son avis il a dit que de
toute façon cette histoire était quand
même
euh assez assez folle et qu' voulait que
la justice fasse son travail mais que
quoi qu'il arrive la vie pour lui de
Stéphane Plaza était brisée parce que
voilà il avait toute toute cette
réputation qui lui collerait à la peau
pendant pendant pendant longemp qu' dit
euh donc notre ami Éric Antoine qui est
qui est formidable aujourd'hui les
résultats de l'enquête interne sont
tombés pour M6 l'enquête interne ne
révèle aucun acte s'appartement de près
ou de loin à de la violence morale ou
physique aucun harcèlement de quelque
nature que ce soit pas de propos sexiste
ou actes pouvant être y être assimilé
Stéphan Plazza et pour réservoir pod la
boîte de production même constat
Stéphane Plazza aime complimenter autrui
afin de créer un lien de sympathie et de
confiance donc les deux enquêtes
internes de la boîte de production et de
la chaîne ont on balayit toutes les
hypothèses de harcèlement que ça soit
harcèlement sexuel moral ou autre tel
puisque comme lib l'avait décrit en
disant que c'était quelqu'un qui avait
un management excessif voire voire des
lateurs et que du coup des l pardon et
que du coup voilà que c'était un mauvais
un mauvais boss et puis qui faisait des
Black Salas sur les tournages qu' qu'il
en profitait pour draguer les candidates
sur sur les plateaux donc tout ça a é
c'est n'importe quoi le conten Deb c'est
hallucinant quand vous lisez l'article
pr
dis lib ce qui est quand même assez vrai
c'est que cette en cette enquête n'a pas
été faite sur énormément de personnes il
y a enfin voilà rés fait une enquête
interne aujourd'hui on a en exclusivité
un communiqué de l'avocat de Stéphan
Plazza qui réagit à ces différente
d'accusation c'est une exclusivité
aujourd'hui à 21h8 personne n' une
réaction ni de l'avocate ni de stè vous
explique dans un premier temps et je
vais vous lire c'est exclu dans un
premier temps que l'animateur ne
souhaite pour l'instant pas s'exprimer
Stéphan Plazza ne souhaite pas
s'exprimer actuellement en particulier
égard au contexte international
toutefois son silence n'est nullement un
aveu bien au contraire donc déjà il
démarre comme ça elle explique également
que Stéphane Plaza est très très affecté
par ses accusations maître Hélène plumet
c'est là donc cab associé c'est un
cabinet et elle est vraiment nous a fait
une réponse et merci à elle en tout cas
il est très affecté aujourd'hui son nom
est s son réseau est attaqué alors qu'il
n'a commis aucun crime ni aucune
violence alors c'est l'avocate de
Stéphan Plazza qui dit ça et qui nous
envoie cela elle continue euh Stéphane
Plaza réitère qu'il n'a jamais été
violent envers quiconque et qu'on se
serve de cette cause le meurtri car des
femmes battues perdent de la vie chaque
jour
elle nous donne ensuite elle nous
redonne comme je vous l'ai dit un
instant les conclusions des différentes
enquêtes internes les en quê interne ont
conclu qu'aucun acte de sa part ne
pouvait s'apparenter de près ou de loin
à de la violence morale ou physique
elle nous parle également de la plainte
pour harcèlement et cyber harcèlement
déposé par Stéphane Plazza lui-même de
son côté il met mettra toutes les
actions en œuvre pour rétablir la vérité
et laver son honneur il a déposé plainte
pour harcèlement et cyberhcèlement bien
avant la sortie de l'article de
Mediapart l'enquête pénale est en cours
et à notre connaissance plusieurs
personnes déposent plainte également
pour harcèlement NOTAM contre les trois
femmes concernées voire menace et
usurpation d'identité car les méthodes
utilisées par les harceleuses relèvent
de la bande
organisée enfin elle déclare que Stéphan
Plaza Stéphane va porter plainte contre
Mediapart et voici par ailleurs il va
attaquer Mediapart et voici pour in jure
et diffamation ainsi que tous les autres
médias qui continueront d'exploiter ses
propos
calomieux Stéphane Plaza il est dans
quel état Hugo actuellement on a c'est
une réponse en exclu vous a fait son
avocat il dans quel état
St au bout du Roule ah oui vraiment bien
sûr au bout du Roule on salie son son
image on salie son travail alors on le
dit toujours ici on croit d'abord les
victimes et jeune femme il y a une
enquête qui va être faite mais lui il
vous dit il vous il dit quoi Stéphane
moi je veux bien que ça soit clair bien
évidemment que j'écoute la parole des
femmes je veux pas que on je suf c'est
une évidence mais moi déjà j'ai j'ai
rencontré à deux reprises
euh de deux femmes qui qui qui ont qui
ont porté plainte contre contre Stéphane
donc j'ai une vision totalement limpide
de ce qui se passe et euh et c'est un
règlement de compte faut que ça soit
très clair c'est un règlement de compte
c'est une vendétat contre Stéphane c'est
pas donc pour l'instant ont réussi à le
faire tomber
bah alors pour l'instant M6 et RTL n'ont
pas lâché ouais mais l'opinion publique
c'est ça le problème c'est que comme on
l'a vu tout à l'heure avec habitant avec
Harry habitant une fois que une image
est dégradé ça ça colle à la peau et et
le temps passant au-delà de détruire un
être ça peut aussi détruire une vie
complète il est je vous sentais très ému
command vous m'avez dit au bout du
rouleau comment vous m'avez dit est au
bout du rouleau je vous ai senti très
ému bah oui parce que ça ça ça fait de
la peine de de voir quelqu'un qui qui
pour moi est quelqu'un de bon quelqu'un
de gentil quelqu'un bien évidemment le
succès lui est monté à la tête voilà on
le comprend bien quand on lit l'article
de lib on voit que ces anecdotes
montrent quelqu'un qui
a mais quand on lit lib on parle de on
donne des exemples de de blague et on
les interprète comme un premier degré
maisf le second degré on l'a oublié dans
ce pays on est où là il est sorti quand
même accessoirement avec plusieurs
femmes en même
temps dit dit c'estd que aujourd'hui si
on sort avec plusieurs femmes en même
temps on est sûr sal con d'accord mais
on mérite pas on mérite pas qu'on nous
gâche notre vie je suis désolé c'est
disproportionné même si ça été un sal
avec femme j'ai aucun doute là-dessus
sûrement il a dû voilà avir plusieurs
conquêtes il a dû trouver même des
maniganes pour essayer de s'en sortir
j'ai aucun doute là-dessus dites que
c'est un con si vous voulez ah non moi
je dis rien mais non mais je parle pas
de vous je dis si vous voulez je parle
de l'opinion publique mais de là à le
harceler comme c'est comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui ça n'a plus de sens non mais
ces histoires comme me disent les les
téléspectateurs il me disent ces
histoires de fess de Stéphan Plazza on
s'en fout total don on a le person après
s'il y a eu des violences là forcément
voilà voilà c'est ça le truc c'est ça le
truc il est là exactement tout le monde
me dit les histoires de PR stphan il
fait ce qu'il veut on s'en fout total
continue à regarder
faire SAF que s'il y a pas eu de
violence alors ce que dit H vrai et ceon
a déjà dit cette semaine c'est qu'il
tomberait pour une question de morale et
pour une histoire de pardon mais
d'intime de fesse et ça je trouve que
c'est terrible sur pour la société parce
que tu as raison de dire
que
attention aprs att j'ai commencé ma
phrase comme ça et hier j'ai dit on doit
d'abordire la parole des des des
victimes et même des supposé victimes
aujourd'hui mais n'empêche que on est on
voit bien qu'on est on est entre deux et
que et que la condamnation elle a déjà
lieu quand même elle elle l'opinion
publique bien sûr sentiment sur St je
vous jure l'opinion publique moi je sens
pas un désamour un désaveux pour Stéphan
Plaz il a une manifestation devant
m6e sur les réseau VO bien qu
même on verra dans les mois à venir
comment on va
évoluer on pense d'abord aux
victimeschezle voilà on le redit non on
le redit s'il y a eu violence c'est
extrêmement grave on le dit voilà si
c'est des vengeances voilà parce que il
y a eu des des exactement bah là là
c'est c'est
in c'est inadmissible et bien sûr voilà
on le dira ici on sera les premiers à le
dire merci Myriam Palom tout de suite le
sang de la vi une histoire Deol qui mal
tourn
c'était votre